hey guys Ryan right here I'm Adele we're
gonna watch the trailer today the first
theatrical trailer for big hero 6
did you see the teaser no I've not even
had anything about it but I love Disney
I love animation yeah but I my limited
knowledge of this is that it's based on
an actual Marvel comic Disney owns
Marvel now so it makes sense that they
could adapt a Marvel comic yeah I mean
the teaser trailer is pretty cute and
funny doesn't really tell you much but
sets up the fun tone so let's see what
the actual trailer has to offer it's
been approved for appropriate people Wow
Oh Sam alright let me get our second San
Francisco a man in a kabuki mask
attacked you with an army of miniature
flying robots
microbots b max tell them yes officer
microbots yeah he was controlling them
telepathically with a neurocranial
transmitter come on I am NOT fast ah so
mr. kabuki was using ESP to attack you
and balloon named
he's dying what's he doing why is he
going so slow because he doesn't move
fast dying I know it sounds crazy kid
how about we call your parents and get
them down
what write your name and number down on
this piece of paper and working well
okay but first we need some upgrades
Oh
a lunatic in a mask just tried to kill
us
how cool is that I mean it's scary
obviously but how cool what's wrong with
you hello bad you home sweetie we jumped
out a window baby that looks like a
little fun that looks like so much fun
it looks like a great time I mean the
action sequences look like they're gonna
be a lot of cool things in there but an
animated movie goes like crazy action I
love it because it's like believable but
just because they're already engrossed
in an animated world and they could go
even crazier than a live-action movie
you know like I love the English
accessory like I'm sorry he did like
Hello with that I like The Incredibles
to me was a fantastic superhero film and
I'm hoping that with a superhero
sequences in this they delivered the
same thing very cool it looks super
exciting I can't wait to go to San Fran
Nokia San Fran Nokia yeah I mean it
looks like cute and adorable yeah so
usually it was adopted from a from a
comic yeah Marvel comic yeah okay no
Marvel is right yeah sorry you're from
Australia so it's pretty I'm sure
Marvel's not overly know there's that
why you went all Iron Man yeah exactly
exactly I know the main kid looks cool I
mean the fat robot looks like a giant
snowman
yeah Marshmallow Man marshmallow Manzo
what do you uh you're just making it
yeah okay he looks marshmallowy
yeah great way marshmallows Wow did you
have an American accent marshmallow
marshmallow you did it marshmallow
okay cool anyway guys if you're new to
the channel you can subscribe to this
button up here and if you're haven't
subscribed to Adele's channel yet her
movie review channel
yes you can that what no I was beautiful
good job does the subscribe dance she
make that a thing now
now when people see me on the street hey
Ryan
Jose send of all you said shoutout
no punctuation no punctuation man like
who do you think I am I very separation
I like that yeah well you like it like
that
that's like he's just he's not telling
you it's well it's whatever you want
looks like a way mystery man mysterious
oh you like a mysterious guy right yeah
how's a sir mysterious Wow Jose she's
really she's liking this
I like the nerve punctuation wow she's
really attracted of that
now when I text you know more
punctuation I'm just gonna leave
everything you Lettieri imagination yeah
well Jose you got your shout out and you
got a del turned on congratulations Jake
Rodriguez just shout out is what he said
okay okay
Jake Rodriguez
how scary would it be at those birds to
start crashing on my way like little
birds dying I know what if like horrible
things are happening to those birds
it sounds like wow Jake now when we hear
about birds dying I'm gonna think of
Jake Rodriguez it's a horrible
reputation I have my friend Kevin out to
Murano Veronica is hot yes that's a fact
and give me a shout-out okay Kevin
I'll altamirano he's probably Italian
and didn't oh yeah Kevin I knew once
knew a guy named Kevin to use a tall ass
[ __ ] Filipina I need you in
Italian accent um Kevin Altamirano Mamma
Mia Pizza Super Mario Brothers I go for
the most cliched minds as possible
anyway uh buddy yeah dude um you know
what your name is with initials k eh I
know but how do you say it as a whole
word K interesting huh ka is one letter
if you think about it K rhymes with gay
ha ha ha ha Kevin you might be yay and
that case that it hit me up man this guy
I might be into it who knows who knows
it's primarily woman I like but you know
if you guys expect Jade balls am I like
you my luck even that Italian [ __ ]
nothing I was gonna say something about
Maria is it I'm gonna sit make a joke
about his [ __ ] in the Leaning Tower of
Pisa but then I didn't get that why
don't you go for it I didn't I missed it
you missed it yeah okay
it was in my brain it was that yeah your
[ __ ] was in her brain it was actually
wow I got like surprisingly really
jealous because of it oh you Kevin Alton
Moreno is my [ __ ] never in your brain
not like Ches
you